♪ ♪
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
BEEN ON A TERROR AGAINST THE
MEDIA OVER THE PAST 24 HOURS,
LABELING THEM THE OPPOSITION
PARTY AFTER THE COVERAGE OF
YESTERDAY'S MEETING WITH
DEMOCRATS.
IT ALL STARTED WITH A LATE-NIGHT
WINTER STORM.
"THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE DISHONEST THAN IT IS
NOW.
NBC AND MSNBC ARE GOING CRAZY.
THEY REPORT STORIES, PURPOSELY,
THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF THE FACTS.
THEY ARE TRULY THE OPPOSITION
PARTY WORKING WITH THE DEMS.
MAY EVEN BE WORSE THAN FAKE NEWS
CNN, IF THAT IS POSSIBLE!"
THEN AS HE'S LEAVING FOR THE
BORDER, TRUMP SAID THIS: >> THE
MEDIA WHICH I CALL THE
OPPOSITION PARTY, A LOT OF THE
MEDIA, IN COORDINATION WITH THE
DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS.
YOU WALKED OUT ON THE DEMOCRATS,
ARE YOU GOING TO BRING THEM
BACK?
HOW CAN YOU GET A DEAL IF YOU'RE
NOT TALKING?
>> I DIDN'T POUND THE TABLE.
I DIDN'T RAISE MY VOICE.
THAT WAS A LIE.
I SAID IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
GIVE A STRONG BORDERS, BYE-BYE
AND I LEFT.
I DIDN'T RANT AND RAVE LIKE YOU
REPORTED.
I VERY CALMLY WALKED OUT OF THE
ROOM.
I DIDN'T SMASH THE TABLE.
I SHOULD HAVE BUT I DIDN'T SMASH
THE TABLE.
>> Jesse: WHILE THE MEDIA
CONTINUES TO TRY TO TRAP TRUMP
IN A LIE, CNN'S JIM ACOSTA
BOTCHED THIS ATTEMPT TO TAKE
DOWN THE PRESIDENT.
>> HERE ARE SOME OF THE STEEL
SLABS THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT HERE.
AS YOU CAN SEE, YES, YOU CAN SEE
THROUGH THE SLATS TO THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE U.S.-MEXICO BORDER.
AS WERE ROCKING ALONG HERE, WERE
NOT SEEING ANY KIND OF IMMINENT
DANGER.
THERE ARE NO MIGRANTS TRYING TO
RUSH TOWARD THE FENCE HERE IN
THE McALLEN, TEXAS, AREA.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THERE ARE
SOME OTHER BUSINESSES BEHIND ME
ALONG THIS HIGHWAY.
THERE IS A GAS STATION,
BURGER KING, AND SO ON BUT NO
SIGN OF THE NATIONAL EMERGENCY
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, IT'S PRETTY
TRANQUIL DOWN HERE.
>> Jesse: PRETTY TRANQUIL
BECAUSE WALLS WORK, JIM.
I THINK YOU JUST MADE THE
PRESIDENT'S POINT FOR HIM.
>> Greg: THAT WAS PAID FOR BY
THE DONALD TRUMP 2020 REELECTION
CAMPAIGN.
HE IS IN A SPOT AT A WALL.
SEE, THERE IS NO PROBLEM HERE.
[LAUGHTER]
HE MAY BE DUMBER THAN WE
INITIALLY THOUGHT WHICH SAYS A
LOT OR I THINK IT COULD BE A
REALLY LONG PRANK.
LIKE ANDY KAUFMAN, WHEN ANDY
KAUFMAN PRETENDED TO BE A
CHARACTER ALL THE WAY UNTIL HIS
DEATH.
I THINK HE'S PLAYING THIS ROLE
AND BY THE WAY, IT'S AMAZING.
THE MEDIA HAS NO CREDIBILITY ON
THIS ISSUE BECAUSE JUST WEEKS
AGO, THEY CALLED THIS A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS, RIGHT?
THERE WERE PEOPLE RUSHING THE
BORDER, CARAVANS, PEOPLE DYING.
SUFFERING.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP AGREES AND
SAYS IT'S HUMANITARIAN CRISIS,
THEY TURN INTO THIS MOCKING
TONE, WHAT CRISIS?
THERE IS NO CRISIS HERE.
LOOK AT THIS WALL.
THEY ARE THE BIGGEST HYPOCRITES.
IT'S HARD NOT TO --
IT'S HARD TO LIKE THEM.
IT'S EASY TO DESPISE THEM.
>> Jedediah: THE PROBLEM IS
HOW OBAMA CALLED IT A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
TRUMP TWEETED OUT.
THE MEDIA IS ON RECORD SO MANY
TIMES AS HAVING DEFENDED HIM AND
DEFENDED CHUCK SCHUMER AND
DEMOCRATS THAT VOTED FOR BORDER
SECURITY THAT NOW THEY ARE
PANICKED ABOUT HOW THEY
CONFLICTED -- CAN FLIP IT TO
HATE TRUMP FOR ESPOUSING THE
VERY SAME THINGS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS DID THAT THE MEDIA
BACK THEM UP ON.
>> Juan: I DON'T GET IT AT ALL
ALL.
>> Jesse: THE MEDIA, ALL OF
THEM GATHERED DOWN THERE TO LOOK
AT THE PHOTO OP AND YOU HAVE THE
BORDER PATROL AND THEY MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT 90% OF THE
TRAFFIC COMES IN THIS SECTOR
WHERE THERE IS NO BARRIER.
ONLY 6% OF THE TRAFFIC COMES
WHERE THERE IS A BARRIER.
SINCE THE MEDIA WOULD TAKE AN
EXPERT OPINION LIKE THIS AND
MAYBE WRITE IT DOWN IN ONE OF
THEIR NEWS STORIES AND SHOW
HATE, THE EXPERTS ON THE GROUND
SAY WALLS WORK.
>> Juan: NO, THAT'S HOW YOU
DISTORT NUMBERS.
>> Jesse: JUAN, I DIDN'T
DISTORT THE NUMBERS.
>> Juan: HERE'S THE REALITY.
THERE'S NOT A WALL ACROSS MOST
OF THE BORDER.
>> Jesse: I UNDERSTAND THAT.
VERY SPECIFIC SECTORS, IT REALLY
SLOWS DOWN TRAFFIC.
>> Juan: LET ME SAY THE MEDIA
WENT DOWN THERE.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF AND I
THINK A LOT OF THE ANGER AT THE
MEDIA CAME FROM THE SESSION WITH
ANCHORS THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
OFF THE RECORD.
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTS THE
PRESIDENT SAID HE DIDN'T WANT TO
GIVE THIS SPEECH ON TUESDAY
NIGHT.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO GO TO THE
BORDER, DIDN'T SEE THE PURPOSE.
AND THEN THE PEOPLE BEHIND HIM,
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS, BILL
SHINE, KELLYANNE CONWAY, THESE
PEOPLE THINK IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
APPARENTLY HE DIDN'T.
HERE'S THE REALITY, YOU HAVE A
SITUATION NOW.
>> Jesse: THEY VIOLATED THE
OFF THE RECORD --
>> Juan: I THOUGHT IT WAS THE
MOST TRANSPARENT PRESIDENT EVER.
HAVE IT ON THE RECORD.
>> Greg: YOU CERTAINLY MIND
READING AFTER YOU KNOW WHAT HE'S
THINKING.
>> Juan: ALL RIGHT, SO THEN HE
RETWEETS.
HE DOESN'T RETWEET THE MEETING.
HE RETWEETS DAN BONGINO, CHARLIE
KURTZ.
HE'S IN THE CONSERVATIVE ECHO
CHAMBER.
>> Jesse: TRUMP IS ACTIVE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
THANK YOU, JUAN.
DANA, YOU HAVE OFF THE RECORD
THINGS AND THEN YOU GO DOWN
THERE FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SHOWCASE THE BORDER.
THE MEDIA IS FOLLOWING ALONG.
DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING TO MAKE
ANY IMPACT WITH THE PRESS
WHATSOEVER?
>> Dana: THE THING ABOUT THE
OFF THE RECORD BEING VIOLATED, I
DON'T THINK IT WAS THAT
EGREGIOUS.
I WOULD NOT LIKE IT IF THAT
HAPPENED TO ME BUT I ALSO WOULD
NOT BE SURPRISED IF THERE
WEREN'T OTHER PEOPLE CALLING
MAGGIE HABERMAN AND TELLING HER
THAT EXACT SAME THING.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
THE WHITE HOUSE WILL SAY THAT'S
NOT TRUE AND THEN THREE MONTHS
LATER YOU FOUND IT'S EXACTLY
WHAT HAPPENED.
THE FACT THAT THE MEDIA, HOW DID
WE FIND OUT TODAY THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE CRACKED THEIR
COALITION?
I READ IT IN A POLITICO HE'S
BECAUSE REPORTERS ARE OUT THERE
DOING THEIR JOBS.
IT'S NOT ALL FAKE NEWS.
SOME OF THE REPORTING IS
ACTUALLY PRETTY GOOD.
THE OTHER THING THAT BOTHERED ME
IS THE OTHER DAY ON THE DAILY,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PODCAST,
THEY TURN THIS CRISIS THING, THE
HEADLINE WAS IT'S A CRISIS
OF HIS OWN MAKING.
BECAUSE THEY SAID HE'D CHANGE
THE ASYLUM RULES AND HOW YOU
APPLY FOR ASYLUM, THAT'S WHY ALL
THESE PEOPLE FLOODED THE BORDER.
IF YOU GO BACK, AS JEDEDIAH WAS
SAYING IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THAT WAS A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
THEY DIDN'T SAY THAT WAS OBAMA'S
OWN MAKING.
IT'S A FRUSTRATING THING BECAUSE
THERE IS CLEARLY A BIAS THEY ARE
OR UNWILLINGNESS TO LOOK BACK
INTO A FAIR COMPARISON.
>> Jedediah: ALSO THE MEXICAN
DRUG CARTELS AND THE DRUG
TRAFFICKING AND WHAT'S GOING ON
IN MEXICO IS NOT PART -- THAT'S
NOT TRUMP'S FAULT.
HE NEEDS TO BROADEN THE
DISCUSSION.
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE THE TERM WALL.
HE NEEDS TO TALK ABOUT BARRIERS
BUT HE ALSO NEEDS TO TALK ABOUT
GOING AFTER THESE CARTELS.
HE NEEDS TO TALK ABOUT PROBLEMS
HE HAS WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT
THAT WANT DIPLOMACY ALL THE TIME
AND DOESN'T PRIORITIZE GOING
AFTER CARTELS.
HE NEEDS TO TALK ABOUT THE
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN MAKING THAT